so rules to get by like I said we're not
gonna really talk about JavaScript much
in this talk but it is relevant to
pretty much everyone because you
probably use some kind of version
control hopefully it's good well
hopefully try and prove to you that it
should be good if it's not but yeah so
my name is Nick nisi I'm an organizer of
this group and the once great nej has
come there are a couple of other
organizers in here we just had that our
last event last month and look for the
videos out coming to YouTube pretty soon
but that was a really fun event
I'm also the MC for typescript comp
which happens next month in Seattle so
if you're interested in typescript and
Seattle can come together for that I
contribute a lot to open source
particularly projects like dojo that's
the one I get paid to do quite a lot and
it's a framework similar to reiax or
view but yeah written completely in
typescript so I kind of if you can't
tell I like typescript a lot and then I
want a couple podcasts the Jay s party
podcast and talk script which digs into
typescript more than anything so yeah
but the way that I describe myself in my
works like is like this specifically
there I consider myself a get custodian
because a lot of times on the projects
that I lead a lot of my time is spent
curating get not because I just have an
obsession with it but to deliver the
correct things and the correct history
to our customers and also to help them
understand why get is important because
we think it is we think that having a
manageable history that you can use to
go back and find things or to understand
how things happened is important and so
I spend a lot of time doing that but I
ask this in the midwest dev chat a
couple of months ago now what is gay or
i can't actually remember what i
specifically asked that i got these
funny responses and it's get gets easier
once you get the basic idea that
branches are homeomorphic endo functors
mapping sub manifolds of a hilbert space
Linux is like if the creator of get
wrote an operating system which is true
Lena's normal - or however you say his
name created get and Linux and so yeah
what what this is saying is get is easy
right uh-huh
it's a distributed version control
system where every one who clones the
repository has the entire history of the
project which is crazy to think that it
used to not be that way
I kind of came in to the world of
writing software using subversion and I
never fully understood subversion and it
blew my mind that you didn't have the
full repository locally and couldn't
just many play things the way that you
can would get with subversion and so I
couldn't believe that that was the way
that we used to to work and my personal
opinion is it's better than subversion
so yeah but those those responses are
those tweaks specifically like they
employ that get is difficult and it's
but it's also kind of pretty great the
CLI is kind of difficult because there's
a lot of weirdness to it and hopefully
we're gonna go through a bit of that
today and then there's a lot of ways to
do different things it's there's more
than one way to do things so there's not
a prescribed path and so everybody just
kind of does get the way that they want
to do get and that's that makes it
pretty great but it also makes it more
difficult but the really great things
about get are that it's distributed like
I said everybody has a version of the
repository locally so if I have my
project and I jump on a plane I can do
anything to that repository and then
sync up later and it'll all be fine it
also offers fast branching and merging
and so a branch is really cheap and get
not so much as I understand from other
version control systems so it's just
really easy to create branches destroy
branches merge tranches do all of that
and then get has a really big social
part to it obviously with github and I
think that it's these three things that
made get popular as opposed to other
things it's more specifically the social
aspect of it because it kind of
solidified and and created a way to do
open source and to do so
where that is repeatable and
maintainable across all projects so you
have these this idea pull requests or
merge requests or whatever you call them
in your your social gate of choice but
it gives you a way to do all of that in
a really easy and repeatable way so that
if I want to go contribute to your
project I don't have to go read through
your mailing list and figure out what I
need to do I just go submit a pull
request or a merge request or whatever
and it's as simple as that so at my job
my day job I'm a JavaScript contractor
basically I go in and help run projects
and customers with their JavaScript
needs primarily in typescript but I and
work with that so I end up working with
a lot of different teams on a lot of
different projects sometimes I go into a
completely green project and I get to
set up the world and it's wonderful most
of the time I go and join a team where
they have years of history and I'm just
going to be contributing a small piece
to it and then moving on or helping them
to figure things out and then moving on
but I get to jump in at a lot of
different with a lot of different
customers that are at different levels
of get understanding
I'd have different ways of doing things
and so this talk is kind of a me trying
to condense down some rules that I came
up with or when I'm working with clients
and trying to preach to them the
benefits of you and so I broke it down
into these three rules that I'll try and
kind of follow and it's one that it's
actually hard to lose history so don't
be afraid to do things with git commit
messages eventually matter so do like
just get things into version control and
then we can clean it up later
and then this one is kind of vague but
the feature of your feature is my future
and I think that I'll explain that a
little bit more but this one is the
biggest pain point that when I come into
projects and they're not doing it
properly
it's the biggest pain for me so I
developed some methods to work around it
and make not and working off of make
working with feature branches off of
feature branches off of feature branches
saying I heard a groan does that mean
that happens yes yeah it happens a lot
so the first rule and specifically what
we'll dig into is the anatomy of a git
repository so remember the the first
rule is that it's actually hard to lose
history let's look at what gets actually
doing to prove that so go to my handy
keynote terminal here and create a new
git repository so I'm just going into a
new directory and then running git init
and so I get this message back that it
has initialized a new empty git
repository I get inside of that
directory and if I use my handy tree
command to go look inside of Duncan this
is what I have in there so this is my
git repository completely most of the
time you don't ever have to think about
this but we're just going to dig into it
to understand small pieces of it just to
show that it's actually hard to lose
history and to give us more confidence
when we're actually doing changes so
specifically we're going to be looking
at reps and objects in here and then
also ahead
but the this object database this is
where get actually stored everything
about your project that it knows so in
here it'll have a bunch of different
directories that it starts creating and
we'll kind of dig into that but off the
off the bat it's pretty simple so if we
have a if we create a new file inside of
this directory and not inside of the get
directory inside of the project
directory
unless I'm just putting in hello world
into a hello DUP txt file and I just
read that out with cat and run get
status this is the message I get so no
commits yeah I'm on branch master and
get knows that there's a file in my
working directory that it's not tracking
so it lets me know that another way that
we can do this is with the git status
desk a short just to make a little
simpler a little bit simpler I'll just
run this command for everything else but
the double question mark just means get
has no idea about this file it's not
tracking it's not doing anything so it
doesn't actually exist to get sighs so
if I run a get log it fails and it tells
me that my master branch does not have
any commits on it so what do we do we
add it let's add the file
using the get add command and now let's
look at the log and it still fails
because we didn't actually add anything
that would be crazy so yeah what that is
doing is it's actually doing something
and get understands that it's doing
something so if we went back and looked
inside of our get directory and inside
of the objects directory we now have a
new file in there a new directory and a
new file and this is an object that get
is now storm so git now understands that
there's a file out there but it's not
doing a whole lot with it quite yet
still not part of the history there's
just this new object in there and what
this object is called is it's a blob and
so this blob object contains the entire
contents of hello dot txt not the file
name itself or anything like that just
the content so in our case the contents
is hello world and how do I know that
this is a blob it has a plumbing tool
called cat file where I can say give me
the type of that file and it will tell
me that it's a blob and what this is
doing is for b5f this is a unique
identifier to that object and so the the
SHA that create that get creates for
that is based off of the contents of the
file and it'll create a directory using
the first two characters of the show
that it creates and then the file name
will be the remaining 38 characters so
it's nice and easily readable and
pronounceable and this is the the
internal blob structure that it's using
so if I ran cat and I just looked at the
contents of that file
it gives me garbage I don't understand
any of that but like I said I can run
cat file - t4 give me the type and it
will give me back that it's a blob and
if I run - P for prints it will give me
back the contents of that file so it
will it'll I'm unencrypted is the wrong
word but it'll do that and give me back
the contents which is just hello world
in this case yeah so yeah
I don't see a file calm or b5f I see a
file called five and a six yep but it's
inside of a directory called 4b so it
doesn't like when you're running these
commands through get itself it's not
looking for it's not asking you to give
it like file name information about this
asking you to give it unique identifier
and so the unique identifier that it
uses is that shot so it's a 40 character
long string and it will be for beat by
this but the way that getting stores
that internally is it will take the
first two letters and make that the
directory name so that when you go like
if you had to go search for this
yourself the the you won't just get an
object or an object directory that has
thousands of files in it you'll get an
object directory that has maybe hundreds
of directories in it that have sub files
in there so every command every commit
or object that starts with four V will
be in this directory and then the
remaining 38 characters will be after
that and so if there was another commit
that I did or blob that I created the or
object that I created that started with
Warby and would just go into that
directory and it's just a way that get
tries to avoid having a single directory
that contains hundreds of okay yeah good
question so the blob structure itself
how did it create that hash that 40
character long string well it took the
type of object that it is in this case
it's a blob and a length so the length
is the content length of the actual file
that we had so remember that file just
contains hello world in it that's 12
characters total here plus a null
character at the end saying that that's
the end of the file and it puts that
after a null character here and so if we
were to run get hash object with that
exact content every single time we'll
get the same hash back we'll get four
b5f and if we did the same thing and
passed it to OpenSSL sha-1 we get the
exact same thing every single time for a
file that has that content will always
get the same blog back or the same sha
back and so that's how get is storing
this internally and it's all based on
the contents of that file what that sha
ends up being and so if you
another file that had the exact same
contents it will only store the one and
it'll just reference it later and we'll
get to how it references it in the next
few slides but that way it only has to
keep track of the contents for this each
time now if I were to go and create
another like let's say we skip all of
this and we go commit and then we create
another another commit and we add
additional content to it maybe we add
hola mundo so hello world in Spanish to
the file given store another blob that
contains the entire contents of that
it'll store hello world in one and then
hola mundo has another completely
different object they will have to go
find but all of this was created when we
ran get add and added that hello txt
file so when we ran get add it didn't
actually commit anything but it what it
did was they added it to the staging
section of git and so this is a step
before the commit process and it might
get early days this was just an
annoyance I had to deal with and then
get a a basically or get add a and then
go straight to commit after that what I
do now is I use the staging section to
be able to piecemeal commits out of that
and so you can do git add - P and I will
allow you to stage different hunks of a
file or chunks of a file and then you
can say that I want to create a commit
where I add a console that log here and
I want to create a another commit where
I added you know a new function down
here and maybe you don't want them
separate or you don't want them together
so you have them s different commits the
staging area is what allows you to do
that so I can work all day long changing
files all day and then just piecemeal
stage things together using the staging
area and create commits off of that and
then I have everything as small as it
can be and what I try and do is keep
commits as small as possible because
when I go back at me to use tools to
find out where my god a regression came
in if the commit is small it's easy to
say that's the commitment did it and
it's easy to see exactly what the
problem is but if it's you know ten
thousand lines that have changed well
yeah that's the commit doesn't really
help
now I have to spend the entire day
looking through the diff for that so
yeah it's just a place that allows the
commits to be built up and focused
rather than just an accumulation of all
of the current changes so what are the
importance of blobs
well the blob object is tied to rule
number one which is it's actually hard
to lose history as soon as I ran get add
get now knows about that and there's a
blob in there so even though it would be
ridiculous to try and go find the
contents of that file if I went and
deleted hello.txt technically I still
have the contents of it inside of git as
a block and it will not disappear any
time soon it will only disappear later
on when garbage collection gets run or
if you manually run garbage collection
but it's there so if I really need it to
go find it it's there so it'll store a
complete copy of that file and then that
that file or that blob will contain the
complete contents and one thing to know
that I don't really get into much in
this is that when garbage collection
does actually run all blobs that stick
around do actually get condensed down
into a pack file and then those pack
files are used so instead of having blob
objects that contain the entire contents
on the file over and over and over it
just contains the file and then dips to
that file going forward so you can still
get out all of it with the git commands
but it's just not as as simple so if I
went and made further commits we've
added we've run get add for hello dot
txt and now I did exactly that I added
the Spanish equivalent to hello dot txt
and I run it get says that now I have
added a new file and that's in the
staging area but I've also made further
modifications to it and then if I just
want to get check out or I think get
restore now maybe then it will undo that
and the contents of the file will just
have hello world in it and it will go
back to just understanding that there
was just the contents there so because I
didn't run and get add again it didn't
create or update the blob at all that
that change is now gone
but so we've added this now let's just
go and commit it so if we run get commit
and give it a commit message then it
will commit that and if we go look in
the get object's directory we have two
new hashes in there 6:39 D + 8 - ad and
what are these two new objects well
they're tree objects and commit objects
so the tree and we can find all of that
out by just running a kept file - T for
each of them to find that out and let's
talk about what trees are so a tree is
just in data that stores information
about file names and permissions that
are associated to different blobs and so
a tree will contain things like the
permission of the file so in this case
644 that's read and write for me read
and read for groups and everyone on the
machine and then the type of file that
it's a object that it's referencing in
this case it's referencing a blob and
this is that that sha for this blob so
for beat by that trees can also
reference other trees and so a tree you
can think of as a directory structure or
a file name so if you had a file a
directory named source there would be a
tree in there called that maps to
another tree called source and then
inside of there it had any files it
would that tree would map to the files
inside of it
but then it would also map to file names
so in this case hello dot txt so it's
saying that the contents of the file
here will have a file name of hello dot
txt in the root directory and it's a
blob and it's file permissions will be
644 so when you go create this when I go
clone this create a file that matches
this and put the contents of this blob
in there and so it stores all of that
and we fruit if we were in get cat file
- P on a - ad that's exactly what it
gives us that is 644 blob and then the
blob object sha and the file name
now the commit structure is pretty
similar it's going to represent REE and
so it'll have the tree in our case 8 -
ad will be the tree that it's
referencing it can also reference other
trees if there's several other trees in
there and it will reference a parent
commit in our case because this is the
first commit that we've ever done it's
empty so gate creates a linked list of
commits so every commit knows about its
parent all the way up and this is one of
the few times where you actually need to
know about computer science E stuff -
and link list to understand what it's
doing but it's not it's just that each
commit references its parent and so on
but then it has author information and
committer information so this would be
the name of the person and the email
address and that's all coming from your
get config and then a timestamp and for
each of these now more times than not
the author and committer are going to be
the same exact
fields and then it has a commit message
but if the where that can change is like
if I authored B commit and then pushed
up the pull request and you and I was
using tabs and you switched it to spaces
and then just committed that but still
attributed it to me you would be the
committer on that and I would still be
the author on that and you'll sometimes
see that in gets github zui where it has
kind of two avatars squished together
that's because one of them is the author
one of them is the committer
but it has all of that information and
this is all of the information that it's
using to create the shop for that so the
main thing that makes this unique
between every commit is you can change
the commit message and then the
timestamp for the author and committer
will probably be different and that will
not always but almost certainly
guarantee that the SHA will be unique
for every commit that you do and then
it's always pointing to a specific tree
so it has a lot of different variables
to change up with the shiz so the the
commits point to a tree object in the
tree object will point to a blob that's
contained within and it will have the
contents of the file so hello not txt
will have the contents hello world and
that's all been committed by me in a
commit message or commit that has the
message initial commit any questions on
the internal blobs yeah
I think so
yeah because it's the tree would point
to well the tree wouldn't point to any
blob objects and so we wouldn't really
have anything to store there and so
that's why I love times you'll see
projects we'll put like a dot get keep
file in there something and that's kind
of been a de facto standard to keep the
refugees around good question we have
questions so the other part inside of
the the get directory is get references
and these are just references or just
simply reps that point to a single
commit and so you can think of
references as the internals for branches
tags or remote branches if you're
pulling from get up or somewhere else
and so if we went and looked in the get
slash reps directory this is what it
would look like by default if you didn't
have any other branches or tags created
it would have our heads directory and
inside of there there would be a file
called master and if we went and looked
at master it would point to a sha we
just have a shot and so if you remember
from a few slides back
6:39 D was the shot for the commitment
the initial commit that we have so
master is now pointing to 639 D and if
we switched and I'm using the new this
is in the latest version of get where
they they're they have experimental
experimental commands called switch
instead of check out and restore instead
of check out I'm switching to a new
branch that I create called feature
branch and if I went and looked inside a
feature branch it's also still pointing
to 639 D because it's just around like a
pointer to that commit and then from
there it would have a pointer to all of
the previous commits along with that
that history
same thing with head I wouldn't look to
get head dot get slash head it will have
a reference to the current branch that
I'm on so it will just have dissing that
it's pointing to feature link but if I
switch back to the previous branch then
look at get head it's just pointing back
to master
so this is how it knows what branch
you're on is whatever head is pointing
to is where you're at so in both cases
it just points to your commit and then
head always points to the current branch
that you're on now there's this new or
they're not new but there's this new
keep saying there's this thing called
the mythical rep log and this is just a
log that keeps track of every where that
head points to and so then from there
you can take actions to get other places
and the cool thing about this is it will
literally update for everything every
time the head changes so if you switch
branches it changes if you make a new
commit that is telling get that like
master for example has a new commit on
it at the top level so that changes the
contents of what head is because well
technically what master is and so it's
pointed to a new commit and it will have
all of that in if we switch between
branches it's changing all of that and
so this is a weak reference to commit
and the way that get works with garbage
collection is every time you you create
these blobs they're not going anywhere
anytime soon they're sorry that blobs
trees or commits anytime you create any
of those they don't just disappear if I
deleted everything outside of that I'd
not get directory those will still be
there and if I delete commits they'll
still be there if I switch branches all
of those objects are still there until
garbage collection runs and what garbage
collection will do is it will look for
objects inside of the objects directory
and see if anything is referencing them
and so that could be is master
referencing them do you have another
branch that is referencing them along
the history so at some point to some
commit that master or any other branch
references does that reference this
commit or and from that commit does it
reference this tree and or this brand
blob if it does keep those around if it
finds things that it can't that aren't
being held on to by some kind of
reference then that's where the garbage
collection comes in it will go and free
those up by deleting those objects and
the only exception to that is the ref
log where this has references to
everything that you've done but this is
a weak reference so it excludes this
from saying is there a
a reason to keep this around that's only
the the rep log then I can just remove
it but otherwise as long as garbage
collection hasn't been run these Oh
longer commits all of your trees all of
your blobs are still there and you can
always go back and reference them and by
always I mean for probably about 30 days
or so so you have time to figure out if
you really mess something up and go back
so it's it's not a bad thing
that that's kind of the main point of
rule number one is that because of this
because there's always a way to find
these blobs and these trees and these
commits it's hard to lose history if you
know where to go and now you know where
to go so it's inside of the get objects
directory and head will always point to
whatever branch you're on master by
default any other branches will also
point to different commits these commits
will point to trees and the trees will
point to blobs so if you know the
commits you can find the trees and find
the file name information and then you
can find the contents of those files the
commits should be different for you so I
think the six 39d would be different oh
that's because I only have a single
commit I'm switching between branches
and everything so my one commit there's
no other reference that I can have in my
simple master the same yeah so these
commits always point to a parent which
makes that that length list that I
talked about and from there you can
always find out who the parent of a
commit is until you get to the first
commit in our case that has no parent
and then you know that that's the first
commander in it or initial commit and
because of this and because the branch
is like if you go actually look at what
branches are holding with those reps
it's just holding a commit a sha in
there and so that's why branching is so
cheap and get
you just say this branching out points
here and then if I commit to that branch
that branch now points to a new commit
that's at the top and then from there
and go back and so at some point when
you branch off like a feature branch for
example we'll probably have some commit
that is in common with the branch that
it was branched off of in our case it's
commit 3 or C 3 and so from there that's
how I know that
it's basically c1 c2 c3 c4 and c6 or
everything that's on feature branch and
then c1 c2 c3 c4 c6 are on master bridge
this should be like c7 they shouldn't
both be the same yep but yeah so they
should have different commits but then
from there get uses this to figure out
how to do things like merges and
rebasing where it'll figure out where
the common commit is between them and
then use that to figure out where to go
next and what to do
so in summary rule number one as soon as
a file is staged at all the contents of
that file are saved and so if you've
deleted that file an accident if your
cat sat on the computer or did anything
and that file is gone you can go back
and find the blob and get it back if it
was really really important and then the
commit trees or commits point to trees
which point to blobs and so as long as
none of them are orphaned along the way
they'll they'll stick around forever but
once they're opened then garbage
collection will eventually pick them up
and then branches and tags will always
point to a single commit so if you need
branding it's to stick around you can
just create a branch and then leave that
branch sitting there and it'll it'll
stick around me and you can push those
branches up to get over wherever you're
hosting so rule rule number two history
is eventually important above all gets a
communication tool that's why it's so
popular is because of the social aspect
of it with github and everything but at
the end of the day when we're making
these commits we're doing it because we
are contributing to a team of other
developers and we have to keep we have
to be able to describe the changes that
were made and that's using dips and
things like that along with the commit
messages that we have so what are we
actually changing and why and so get is
that can
eunuch Asian tool and this is a quote
for me it gets great and easy in this
example until you have to work with
others then it becomes more difficult
but it tells the chronological story of
what happened in your repository so you
get this spaghetti of everything that
happened all along the way and I think
that that is not the way that it should
be and this is where the commit messages
matter eventually I think that gate
should tell the chronological story of
what should have happened in your in
your project because that makes things a
lot easier and cleaner if you need to go
back and and fix things later so when
the biggest thing that happens with this
is the biggest thing that happens with
this is people develop different
strategies of keeping things around that
is everything from how do we committee
we have special commits like rules that
we follow for the commit logs to do we
do branching with rebasing or do we
merge how do we do all of this and so
that's kind of the big thing that I'm
going to talk about in this one is
rebase or merge which one is better and
I think that both of them have their
merits there's pros and cons there's
really only rebates long wait the pros
are that the history remains flat and
readable and then suppose superfluous
commits are likely non-existent because
you have manicured your your history to
be exactly what you want it to be in
nothing else the cons to that is it can
be dangerous because rebasing means that
you are changing history and when you
change history then you have to force
push history up and if you're doing that
at all where you shouldn't be which is
any branch that someone else might be
looking at then that becomes really
dangerous I've done it I've done it in
like on a real production project for
several months it's not fun for anybody
involved and another con is that yeah
you always have to use the force like
when you push things out but if you're
on a branch that you know that only
you're looking at then force is fine
it's totally great and actually there's
an easier force with lease command that
should be the default I think that will
actually fail the force if history has
changed out from under you
so if somebody else forced pushed and
then you try and force motion it's not
gonna delete theirs and put yours in
there of course with lease will fail
your your force push and let you know so
that you can go have a discussion
because it's a social tool and then
merge the pros of this are traceability
the merge commits will always show the
historical information of the entire
branch history so you can see where you
branched off all the commits that were
added to that and then you have a merge
commit that goes and puts that back into
the master or the develop branch or
whatever and from there the con of that
is history becomes very polluted there
is there are ways to work around this
with tools also I'm only talking about
get command-line tools because in my
opinion and I understand that it's only
my opinion the command line is the one
true way but I won't get into that but
things like first parents flag can be
helpful with hiding superfluous
information but the another con is that
if a feature branch has any irrelevant
commits in there they're part of the new
history and if you don't rebase
correctly or merge quickly you might
have duplicates of commits in there that
have the same history and same commit
messages with different jaws and then
things just get out of control so my
preference is this nice rebase based
history this is an actual project the
dojo project that I work on everything
is linear
everything is easy to find you can go
through and you can see this is where
the head is oh that's where we tagged
6.0 alpha 14 well there's no retyped 6.0
alpha 13 and this is everything in
between so if I wanted to find out what
changed between those two nice and easy
to follow and it's just the same thing
going all the way down so nice and easy
this is another project I use a lot
called typescript and I don't know
what's going on I went back a little
ways but if you look through pretty much
the whole history it looks kind of like
this and that's okay they make it work
obviously they're like the most popular
project on github so I'm not saying you
have to be like this but it is nicer and
it's easier to find things and find
where things went wrong as opposed to
this I have no idea what's going on
if we look at a rebase in action you
start with a commit and we might add
several commits to that and then
eventually we branch off from those
commits and create our feature bridge so
c3 c5 is our feature branch that's all
based off of c1 so what get rebase will
do is it's going to identify the new
commits that have happened since
branching and this is where if we're
running the git rebase and we say git
rebase awful whatever the latest in this
case master is find out what the latest
commits are and then we're going to find
out where the common commit is between
them so we know these are the new
commits this is the common commit that
is shared between both histories and so
what we want to do rebase we'll take the
history from the common commit point and
it will basically lift up those commits
and move them to the end and so they're
based off of the new latest history and
so that's why you get new Shaw's every
time you do a rebase is because the
parent commit has changed which will
even if everything else about the commit
has stayed the same the parent commit
has changed and so it will create a new
shot for that but now we have a nice
linear history and this is how the
history stays linear for everything but
one tool can be can make both strategies
really useful and that's the interactive
rebase which I use a ton all the time
rewriting history because I want I don't
want my co-workers to see any more
poorly my clients to see the mess of
work-in-progress work in progress I
think it's working it's not working all
of these terrible commitments but I have
all the time I want it to be just a
couple of commits like oh you know mix
thing fix this added this like very very
same commits that are very small in
structure that I used to get staging to
structure them correctly and I do that
by committing all of those work compress
work-in-progress all the time and then
before I submit the PO request or maybe
after I submit the PO request and it
gets approved I'd go and prune things
out using the interactive rebase and
that's because as michael crichton said
good books aren't written they're
rewritten and he wrote dresser park
yeah the first one was at least it was
at least good so when you run git rebase
- I or - - interactive and you give it a
commit and this is a commit from the
past that you want to rebase off of it's
going to go and pull all of the commits
into your editor for the latest head to
that commit and so it'll have everything
in there and then it has these verbs
next to it so by default it's always
pick pick pick pick pick and so it's
going to pick that and if I just hit
save and quit then it's basically not
going to change anything because nothing
has changed it I've picked all the
commits to be there but there are all of
these other commands that I can do
rework so that would reword the commit
message but keep the commit the same
yeah keep the commit the same other
words edit is when I use a lot that well
let me go in and say and this was a good
commit but I had a bunch of comfortable
logs in there that I should have that so
I can go edit that delete those and then
save that as the same commitment - the
commit messages or the console that log
messages and now I've rewritten to have
a perfect history with them if it's just
a commit where I basically like did the
same thing but I just committed like
remove console log messages I can use
fix up or squash and that will take the
commit and just squash it or push it
into the previous minute the parent
commit or the one just above it and then
now it's part of that and if you use
squash it concatenates the commit
message from that commit into that one
if you use fix up it just drops the
commit message for that one and makes it
part of the the other commit and then
there's other ones like x4 execute you
can exit run a command if you wanted to
do different things you can tell it to
stop here so that you can basically have
full control of making different changes
you can drop a command you can also just
delete that commit from this list like
if I deleted this one I'd see a comm
like the lead of that it's like that
commitment never existed so you can
easily get rid of history you can easily
change history and you can easily ruin
your day right here but as we learned
with rule number one it's actually hard
to lose history so you can go back and
find those probably using the ref log in
this case but the point of all of this
is that
you should really only keep the commits
that matter and this works with either
strategy that you're using so if you
were creating a feature branch and you
know that that full history of the
feature range is going to be merged
proven that down to remove all of the
work of progress commits or at least
reword them to not get that in there so
that it looks a little more professional
so with that clean history matters
because clean history tells the story of
how the project should have happened and
it's approachable to new developers on
the project if you are a new developer
on typescript and you go look at that
and you try and figure out what is going
on it's gonna be really difficult as
opposed to the other project I showed
where everything is nice and linear and
you can see what's happening and you can
see everything that has happened and you
can go look at those commits and they're
nice and easy and understandable so it's
really easy this allows you to also more
easily utilize tools that get provides
you things like bisect which we'll look
at next which allows you to find
regressions with these and above all a
clean history just keeps you safe so one
tool that I wanted to call out
specifically is bisect has anyone used
bisectors
yeah nice a good good show of hands it's
a really helpful tool that allows you to
find where something is different and
that difference could be right or wrong
in the repository so that could be bugs
in a lot of cases Oh a bug was
introduced I need to go find out what
commits introduce that because I know at
some point it was working or the way
that I end up using it a lot is with bug
fixes where I'm anniver like a branch
for a specific version of the open
source project I'm working on and I know
that it was fixed in this branch now I
need to go apply it to the previous
branches so like first I'm on you know
version 1.13 I need to apply that to
1.12 1.10 1.9 I've never done branches
for each of those I have to go find
where that is and so git bisect allows
you to do that by effectively dropping
you into the middle of a commit range
that you give it and then you tell it
you go in run some tests where you can
automate the test and you tell it
whether or not it was the problem or the
solution exists there with these good or
bad flags and that's really confusing
especially if you're trying to find a
bug fix then I'm saying oh it it was
fixed here so that is bad
but no it's not fixed here so that's
good and like you like it's really
confusing but it allows you to change
those so we'll see that on the next
slide and this is another computer
science II term the what it's doing is
effectively a binary search it's going
to drop you in the middle and then you
say good or bad and if you say good it
goes up here if you say bad it goes down
here and picks the next drops you in the
the middle of those other half of
commits and so you don't have to look at
every single commit it's just going to
keep dropping you in the middle of the
commit range that it's condensing down
so you only have to look at I've I think
the most I've ever had to look at is
like 10 commits there's not not terrible
so let's run a quick experiment a random
egg let's say that we had a script like
this that's going to create a file
called egg dot txt and it's going to do
20 commits so for 1 in 20 we're going to
echo if the commit that we're in is
equal to the random number that I picked
out of 20 then we're going to commit
here's the egg in there otherwise we're
just going to echo in no egg in there
and so basically one of the 20 commits
at some point we'll add here's the egg
in there and so we're going to use get
bisect to find out which commit out of
this random script added here's the egg
so if we did get long - that's one line
- - graph we have 20 minutes we have our
initial commit and then we have 20
random commits that we know were just
put in there by the script and so our
commit messages aren't being very
helpful here we're not able to find out
which one added the egg from this so
what we can do is we can say get by sex
start and here is where I'm doing -
Jeff's term old so instead of saying
good or bad I'm going to say that when
it's old and so I'm saying bad I'm going
to say there's no availa and when it's
good or new I'm going to say egg make it
you either more confusing or less
confusing depending on
you're looking at this so then you say
get by sex start and I'm going to say
get my sex knowing so I know the egg
does not exist at seven one nine but I
know the egg exists at the latest commit
commit twenty head it means I think it
means it's going to go backwards oh I
think old means backwards and new means
forwards I think I'll probably be wrong
on that but I think so yeah so this is
where I'm telling it my parameters I'm
saying that at some point so I'm saying
seven one nine which here seven one nine
is the initial commit there's no egg in
there at seven one month and there is an
egg that commits twenty so seven six
eight and so then I start and it's
telling me that there are roughly nine
revisions that I have to go through so
that means roughly three steps so I have
at most three steps until I find exactly
which commit edit that so we've put me
right in the middle of that I random
commit ten so now that's basically what
I have checked out on the project and so
if I do a cat and I see here's the egg
well good now I can say the egg is in
there so I say get bisect a and so it'll
give me four revisions left so two snips
left so now I'm at random commit five
and in here here's the egg the egg is
still in there
so I said git bisect egg it drops me
into random commit to still there get my
sect egg and I run that now I run git
bisect Noack so now the egg does not
exist or I'm starting knowing when I cat
that out so it doesn't exist at random
commit one and so then wanting to run
git bisect no egg here then it tells me
you're done
the first commit that added that was
random commit too so it was easily able
to with just enough steps that can fit
on one slide find out exactly which
commit out of this and so this could be
like in a real world example this could
be drop me up this command let me run
NPM test and let me test run the test
and see or the test failing here no
let's just really hear yes and if it's
something as simple as that like I run
this commit and it fails or it doesn't
fail if if it's as simple as that then
you can automate bisect and tell it
exactly what command to run and if that
command returns nonzero that it fails if
it returns zero then it succeeds and it
will just run the entire basic for you
and spit out the commit that has that
right at the end so nice and easy easy
way to do this like I said the most
common use for me is finding bug fixes
and then after that bug where bugs were
introduced because I hardly ever
introduced bugs
let's be honest that's not true at all
so yeah that is is bisect any questions
on that so have one more rule and that
is the feature of my feature is my
future and this was a tough rule to name
but this is something that comes that
that happens to me a lot in projects
that I'm just jumping into or I'll give
you a specific use case I was on a
project where we were developing a
design library for a client and I was on
this project for 15 months and ten of
those fifteen months I was developing
one web component just a single one and
it was a grid so it was massive right
and this grid had editable cells in it
which used other web components that
they were creating along the side at the
same time as us so it would have text
fields or number fields or drop downs or
selects or combo boxes and all of these
different things and as they were
developing them
we were also developing and so they had
they were using get the get flow
strategy and they had a develop branch
and so we branched off of develop and
created our branch and that branch stuck
around for 10 months it was a
long-running feature branch not super
fun but from there we kind of had our
baseline of work and then we would
branch off of that and say okay now I'm
going to add the ability to edit cells
and that would be a new branch and so
that would be a future branch off of my
feature branch and then eventually I
would bring that back but at some point
I'm going to need the other components
that were being developed by another
team that was part of this big company
and so I would have to rebase those
commits it because if I
did it merge than my history gets all
messed up and I can't figure out left
from right and it's it's tough to like
give them a change log based on what
we're actually delivering you know every
month and so I would go in every morning
and do a rebase pulling their latest
stuff in and then rebase all of the
independent branches off of that and at
first I didn't know what the heck I was
doing and so it was just a lot of pain
but I will quickly learned a way to do
this more easily without losing any
history and without having to just
suffer every single day so yeah so the
long-running branch this is kind of the
scenario I just explained where you have
maybe master and then you have a bunch
of commits going off developed and then
here's our long-running branch so
they've committed three commits after
that I've got my long-running branches
and then I've got features that are
based off of that and so we're just
trying to keep everything a nice flat
structure without going insane so when I
get check out long-running branch and if
I were to run git rebase developed and
if I did that what that would do
remember rebase will take the it'll go
find the common commit and say okay all
of these commits after that are part of
what's new on long-running branch and
here's the latest commit on long-running
brand or on develop because that's what
I'm rebasing off of I need to reapply
those commits here and so it will
effectively be the same commits but I
added the comment in there to indicate
that they are new shots so C 3 is the
same commit as secret come up as our
apostrophe is the same thing as C 3 but
it's a different shot because of that
but now long-running branches over here
now these feature branches that I was
working on are problematic because now
if when if I tried to get rebase
developer rebased long-running branch
again it's gonna go try and find the
common commit between what is now a
long-running branch and feature branch
and now technically C 2 is the common
event between them so it would reapply C
3 C 4 C 5 C 9
c-13 and c14
over here so now I would immediately
have duplicate commits of C 3 C 4 C 5
and C 9 on there and it would just be
problematic because gets just looking at
the commit Shaw's and seeing that
they're different so if we wanted to do
this what we would want to do this is
what would happen is it would do do that
and now we have all of this and it's we
have these double commits in there so
kind of terrifying this is what I was
doing for a while and it was not fun I
eventually went back and cleaned it up
but super not fun at all
so the issues with that is that get just
doesn't know that C 9 and C 9 c9 tick
are essentially the same commit because
it was rebased and now it has a new sha
so to complete this rebased properly we
have to reapply the commits but we have
to be able to tailgate specifically what
to rebase because gets not smart enough
to do it on its own luckily we are so
git has a really handy tool called git
rebase - - onto which took me forever to
figure out that it exists but once I did
it was just amazing and so with this it
gives you more control more granular
control and you can say git rebase - -
on - so this in this case it would be
developed I want to rebase it on - or
feature branch long-running branch gary
based - - on - long-running branch from
the starting commits so i would tell it
where the actual changes are and then it
would either go to head or it could
specify the ending commit from them
so if we wanted to do that we check out
long-running branch and then we say git
rebase develop what that's going to do
is it's going to sorry we do run git
rebase - onto the long-running branch c9
what we've said is we're on feature one
we want to say we want to rebase onto
the new long-running branch from c9
because that was the last commit that
was actually where we branched off up
here from so C 10 and C 11 are the only
new commits that were on feature one but
we want it to be a part of the new
long-running branch so we tell it
specifically to run from commit nine and
rebates on to long-running branch and
then we only have those two
so now we have a nice clean linear
history for PG one branch that makes
sense now this can get really confusing
as you're going along because if you're
going along and you're constantly doing
this every morning like I was basically
to keep my branches in line and I
basically taught the other developers to
do the same to keep their branches up to
date with everything but I would go and
do it for our long-running feature
branch every morning and then that way
they just knew how to do this
the problem was sometimes it got really
confusing about where the actual last
commit was more specifically what the
first commit was for the feature branch
that you're on so if you remember oh the
feature I'm on is always you know this
something with this commit message then
it's nice and easy but that wasn't
always easy case a lot of times it was
just which is the last commit that I had
and then go one beyond that but if I was
the last one to also commit to the
long-running branch then that's where it
gets more confusing so a tip that I have
is to use an empty commit as a separator
and the reason I say an empty commit
instead of like a tag or something for
that is because the empty commit will
follow the branch around as your
rebasing it every day
and so with that you have some kind of
separator comment in there that makes it
nice and easy and stick out in your
history and then you just interactive
rebase that out of there when you're
actually done and ready to merge it or
rebase it into master and everything is
good so the way that you do that is get
commit - - allow empty and then give it
like a message like separator for
feature one or something and now when
you look at your branches I can see
here's the first commit of this new
feature branch every time and it's just
an empty commit so I can go delete this
commit later on and it won't affect
anything about my actual branch but
that's the that's where it is so every
day I just pick the one before that in
this case dc-3 and I read a special on
tube from there and keep going any
questions yeah
because so I eventually want it to be
off of CNN tic but these two commits are
effectively the same however when get is
going through the history to find the
common committee if I just ran git
rebase gets gonna automatically try and
find the common commit and it's going to
go all the way back down to c2 as the
common commit between them what -
stretch on - it's allowing me to say I
want to rebase onto this branch and then
it allows me to specify the come and
commit myself and so I know that c9 was
actually the common commit here so then
it will take all of the commits after
that and rebase the money that make
sense yeah yeah yeah good point very
good point so like in in the case of
this where I have the separator
you could do the separator carrot and
that would be that's just telling it
take this commit and then the carrot
means the one before that in my case I
always just looked at this and manually
like selected the one before that but I
wanted to write a script which would be
the smart thing to do it would be to use
the care good call so those are the
rules that had there's actually lots
more anyone have going but I'll just
leave you with that tip that I had which
was use force with lease when you're
doing this to make sure that you don't
accidentally Club or somebody else's
commits cool thank you